I'm also scared to have kids because I
live in New York
you know like I get that it's beautiful
and iconic but also the rats have
personality like
it's a jarring place to live
I'll give you my best example of why I'm
scared right there was a while back
where I was on subway I remember where I
was headed but things were going well
you know I I was listening to a podcast
I was having a good day right and I
remember I was sitting on the train and
as I was sitting down this dude got on
the train and sat across from me and
this guy is crazy
okay now I know you're not supposed to
say that I know that's dismissive but
personally I feel like political
correctness Works in proximity to the
problem okay
if I've been watching this dude a
documentary I believe he is an
individual having an episode all right
but because he is four feet away from me
he is crazy okay and he's being crazy
right now my man is sitting down having
a very specific argument with somebody
that nobody can see all right ain't not
even looking across at me he looking
down so it's like a little Gremlin or
something
as neither the type of argument you can
interject it he's just like I ain't out
of the cello all right
so that's happening
as that's happening
the emergency doors open which is never
good
no emergency doors ever open anywhere
and people were like what's about to
happen that's always bad
hence the name
and this dude comes to the door and look
out of respect I will use politically
correct term for him because he has this
situation than the first two this guy is
crazy okay this guy couldn't be
crazy first of all he came through the
door sideways which is a strong choice
I've been walking through doors all my
life and I've been just doing it front
ways like I had no idea I guess I'm just
vanilla like that like I've been walking
through doors missionary and everything
this whole time
but my man walked in the door sideways
making weird noises doing Michael
Jackson moves and stuff my man came in
the door just like
non-stop okay and not busting for money
this is coming out of his spirit all
right just non-stop
okay also should point out no shirt no
shoes no socks just pants fly open and
the only reasons man's pants hadn't
Fallen to the ground was because he had
a big booty and a big dick all right my
man's pants are hanging off her dear
life he just
this dude is so crazy that the
crazy guy stopped being crazy
foreign
[Applause]
y'all see him with his dick out like
that isn't that nasty starts
commiserating with us
I'm like this is how he felt about you
this is wild
that's why I don't feel bad calling him
crazy because it's clearly not a
permanent situation he see dick and he
loose it
oh
foreign
and the reason that I'm scared to have
kids
isn't because the crazy guy
it's not because of the crazy
guy it's because while all of this was
going down there was a kid on the train
that barely reacted
crazy who got in sat down I was like I
all of the jello and then little man
next to me could be more than eight
years old was sitting there reading a
Captain America comic looked at him and
was saying
that'll work itself out
I got on like it's like let's see what
the Red Skull is up to
like I don't know if I'm actually more
scare the crazy guy the crazy
guy or the kids
you should only be that stalk if you've
seen combat all right
and it only happened at the end of last
year so I still think about where that
kid is all the time
he probably on a playground right now
just
putting out a cigarette on his own hands